this is the Eastern Ukrainian city of
bahut in summer 2022 and this is what it
looked like half a year later
Moscow has been trying to take bakmut
since last July turning it into the site
of the bloodiest fight of Russia's war
in Ukraine
while some military analysts and Western
officials have debated how important the
city is to the overall conflict both
Moscow and Kiev have doubled down on
their military operations
turned into a political symbol for Kiev
and Moscow and why this battle has been
so difficult for both sides
located in the highly contested the
netsk region bakhmots wasn't an obvious
spot on the map to become one of the
focal points of the war the city does
sit on a number of major roads linking
it to strategically important locations
in the region
[Music]
but bahut itself isn't a significant
Transportation Hub According to some
military analysts and the city's hilly
terrain makes it a difficult place to
advance from if the Russians do
eventually take backward they will have
to go over Higher Ground and the
ukrainians have had plenty of time to
build highly defensible positions there
some of those positions are in the town
of chasiviar that sits on a hill around
six miles west where ukrainians have
been digging trenches more can be found
further west in crematorsk and sloviansk
the heavily fortified Ukrainian
strongholds in Donetsk it's not going to
be easy for the Russians from from now
on even if they take the city
this makes it unlikely that take troll
of the city would be a turning point for
Russia
so why have both sides continued to
fight for the city
Ukrainian commanders say they aim to
exhaust Russian forces there and give
themselves time to prepare for
offensives of Their Own and for Russia
the battle has turned into a defining
moment for Wagner the mercenary group
that spearheaded the Russian offensive
thanks to them the region surrounding
the city is one of the few places where
Moscow has made any major progress since
last summer but to do this the group has
invested almost its entire supply of
recruits sending waves of soldiers to
near certain death
in March a UK military advisor estimated
that between twenty thousand and thirty
thousand Russian troops have been killed
or wounded in the area around Bahamut
since the start of the offensive
bachmood has developed a symbolic
significance far greater than the
operational or strategic significance of
the city
and Military analysts say Ukraine's
losses which are classified are also
increasing Russian and Ukrainian
military officials didn't respond to our
request for comment on the number of
casualties they've suffered in Bahamut
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has come under criticism at home for
deciding to defend Fortress as he called
it despite mounting deaths
but in late March Western officials and
some military analysts said Russia's
offensive in Bahamut was losing momentum
it may be that the Russians have
effectively exhausted themselves or it
may be that the Russians are just
pausing hoping to resupply and go at it
again with one final with one final push
despite questions about the city's
strategic importance the large number of
troops and ammunition that both sides
have poured into the battle has created
a military significance of its own the
next thing really to watch
will be what happens when a Ukrainian
forces
re-equipped with Western tanks and other
sophisticated equipment and tried to
take back more land occupied by the
Russians